c'est parti pour trois semaines de
vendanges au domaine de l'eau les biens
32 hectares de cépage chenin dans
l'appellation azay-le-rideau doivent
être récoltées par une vingtaine de
vendangeurs le moment le plus fort de
l'année pour la viticultrice marielle
henrion issue elle d'une famille
paysanne chez mes parents en agriculture
les temps forts c'était la moisson qui
était un moment très intense et puis
avec beaucoup de fatigue mais c'était
meilleur moment de l'année parce que
justement c'est la récompense de tous
ses efforts avec une formation de nos
log marielle aurions connaît bien son
raisin est grave comme ça enfin pour on
voit apparaître ce qu'on appelle ridoré
on n'est pas sûr de la maladie et puis
on voit que la grappe elle est quand
même relativement doré sur son ensemble
et qui a pas trop de verre une vendange
qui donnera 180 mille bouteilles après
passage par le che autour de parcelles
c'est qu'elle partait on va aller
ensuite comprendre la stratégie d'arrêt
à moscou entre pressoir et cuves en inox
marielle henrion utilise la méthode
champenoise originaire de la champagne
donc il ya eu énormément de travail mené
sur le pressurage en champagne
donc voilà je me suis adapté à la région
ces pages d'ailleurs le jus de raisin
dit déjà le millésime 2020
marielle commence sa dix septième
vendanges en appellation azay-le-rideau
c'est du jus de retard mais c'est bon ça
sympa c est fruitée meilhan grande
petite touche d'acidité donc c'est
plutôt bon signe